et si cette année pour les fêtes vous
mettiez l'accent sur les produits locaux
vin biscuit charcuterie ou même foie
gras pour sa 12e édition le salon vin et
saveur de poissie organisé par le Lyon
club a réuni des producteurs de toute la
France c'est le cas de cette biscuiterie
de crépière qui fonctionne en circuit
court on a une biscuiterie artisanale
qui a été créé il y a 11 ans et on a
ouvert notre mièlerie au départ avec des
ruches sur la ferme et ça s'est étendu
sur des ruches un peu partout en
île-de-fance l'idée c'est de valoriser
les produits du terroir d'île-de-fance
on essaie vraiment de montrer que le
terroir d'Île-de-France c'est un terroir
de de tradition et de qualité pur beurre
chocolat noisette ou même Coclico ici
les biscuits se déclinent sous toutes
les saveurs même les plus insolides
comme la pétale de rose pour ces
biscuits de marille sur
[Applaudissements]
mold autre tendance des fêes de fin
d'année le vin et les ivelines aussi ont
leur vignobl on propose les vins qu'on
fait dans les ivelines sur la plaine de
Versailles au village d'Avron donc c'est
les premières domaines vol de France une
mise en avant des produits locaux qui ne
laissent pas insensibles les visiteurs
alors le salon vin et saveur nous on le
connaît déjà depuis 2 ans et c'est parce
que les exposants c'est souvent les
mêmes d'une année sur l'autre mais ils
sont tous excellents et donc voilà c'est
l'occasion de profiter de bons produits
du terroir et de la région on a déjà
acheté du
des là on va aller voir FO voilà on a
acheté du SER le plus dur reste donc de
choisir quels produits seront les stars
de nos dîners de fin
d'année